morning everyone
welcome to today's meeting of the
licensing
um committee
um
the file alarm procedure if the fire
alarm is activated please take the
stairs down to the reception area and
out of the building to the green and
holy Square which is the assembly point
please do not use the lifts officers
will assist you an advise when it is
deemed safe to return to the council
offices filming of the meeting does
anybody intend filming the meeting
no okay
um restriction of the use of mobile
phones with everyone present please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned silent and that they are not used
to make obviously phone calls whilst the
meeting is in progress
apologies for absence
are there any apologies for absence I've
got Council of Dennis down
uh cancer Aura Center apologies
councilor Ara
um I've had um apologies from counselor
wing and she said possibly
um
um counselor sorry
Abby's yes Smith yeah um may not be
attending it doesn't look like she's
here
um we had any other apologies
no
okay
Declarations of Interest are there any
Declarations of Interest
no
um I mean it's the last licensing board
meeting please can I have a member
propose and second at the minutes the
licensing board meeting held on the 14th
of February 2023 be approved as a
correct record
councilor May Saunders proposed and
councilor
oh what was that one
[Music]
station in the last minutes the ball
agreed that the item will be deferred to
the next meeting is to do with whether
it can make this is a confidential item
or not but the decision that we took
okay thank you
so sorry can you expand upon that
the minute said that well I didn't agree
the media it's because there was a I
think that the decision that we took at
the last meeting with the private hard
vehicle
driver
wasn't confidential
so you were going to get a legal opinion
on that okay
thanks
have you done that
yeah I've made a no fan of look after
this meeting
okay agenda item four minutes of the
last licensing subcommittee meeting
please can I have a member propose and
second at the minutes of the licensing
board meeting held on the 23rd of
February 2023 be approved as a correct
record
can I have a proposer
Curry and secondary um counselor um
shrub
confirm Council
she's not saying Assurance it basically
reviewed
um
changes to the driver's Knowledge Test
please can I ask Miss Allison Brock
um technical support team manager to
present the report
foreign
everyone
um as you can see it's got a
comprehensive report and there's
information from the sanit private hire
Association in there as well so I hope
you've all had time to be able to read
it all and digest it all
um they the Sonic private hire
Association
um put in representations last November
and arranged a meeting with Craig
McKinley to discuss our current driver
Knowledge Test
because they feel that it's too
difficult and there's not enough drivers
passing it
they also don't necessarily see
especially for private high drivers they
don't see the requirement for the local
knowledge side of it because mainly
because they use sat navs
um
as you can see there last year there was
quite a lot of drivers that didn't renew
over 101 didn't bother renewing last
year
um
last year as well the government in
April bought in the new tax regs where
when they renew their license they have
to inform us and give us their tax code
so that we know they're registered for
tax
some of my team spent a little while
last week phoning some of these drivers
who didn't renew and various reasons
they'd retired they'd moved out the area
um it was too expensive with the circuit
fee the insurance the petrol going up
and some of them also said that it was
because of the tax
because a lot of them were doing it as a
little bit of extra pocket money
and all of a sudden they were having to
say they were doing it you know by the
tax rate so
there was there was a few that said that
as you know with
drivers our main responsibility is the
safety of the public
um there's obviously but yeah you as
board members have seen some of the
drivers you've had drivers before you
recently with various driving issues or
you know things they've done wrong so
you know we obviously have to
make sure that everyone who wants to be
a driver is a fit and proper person
and that there is as it says their fit
and proper person basically would you
allow a member of your family to get in
a vehicle on their own with that person
we're more than happy to make any
changes to the knowledge tests that you
see fit you know whether it's I
personally at the moment we have a
private we have the Knowledge Test
which everyone has to do and then we
have a Hackney test which once they've
passed the knowledge test if they want
to be a Hackney driver they have to do
the extra five questions of a to B Roots
within the area
I would personally like to see it split
a bit more so that there's a private
hire test and there's a Hackney test and
then obviously the Hackney one can
concentrate more on local knowledge or
how to get from A to B because obviously
with a Hackney they're different you can
just hire them in the street you can
just flag one down you can just jump in
it you don't have to book it so they
don't always know when you get in that
vehicle where you're going
and obviously with us being a tourist
area we do like the idea of local
knowledge
because even with a private hire if
someone comes and picks you up from your
hotel to take to you to whatever res you
know restaurant or whatever you're going
to it's
it's normal for people to chat you chat
to the driver you might say oh I'm here
for a week you know do you know where
so-and-so is is there such and such I
could go to it's just uh what you do
isn't it when you're in when you're in
so we do feel local knowledge is
important
we do feel that local knowledge is
um obviously the other issue we have
with some of the courses that take place
at the moment especially the
safeguarding one
it's an online course but
anybody could I could be sitting there
doing that course
because
there's no checks as to who's actually
doing the course
you literally you pay for the course you
get a link to the course and then you
log on and you just do it but there's no
checks they don't know who's doing that
course
whereas the slightly more expensive one
the 25 pound one it is done in a
classroom it's online still but they can
see who's doing it and you have to show
some form of ID
so they can you know they know that
who's who's doing the test
so that's basically it really over to
you to fire us any questions and
counselor pot
thank you and thank you very much for
your report I have got a couple of
thoughts
um I totally agree with the online thing
I think you should be able to see
who is actually sitting it just as a
safeguard
secondly is there any way of bringing in
an international DBS check
four drivers because we have no
knowledge
of what's happened in their country I've
got no objection to any driver but I
think we have to have a DBS check but
it's only for this country if they're
from another country I think it should
be a stipulation because with children
we do need to safeguard
so is that possible
and lastly for the moment is there
another way that we can I do agree that
I think that the uh knowledge we have is
is very difficult
not just for foreign drivers for English
drivers too for everyone across the
border I think it is a bit too difficult
but is there a way you can bring in
another tier
I agree with you for Hackney that is a
really good idea but is there a way that
you can do bring in another tier for say
for drivers that just want to do school
runs that don't can't necessarily want
to become a taxi driver is there another
way we can bring other people in on
board that can do other jobs but not
necessarily the full works
thank you Council
yeah we can do
um obviously there are other authorities
that do do a license just for somebody
who may want to just do school runs
um so that is something we can look into
and as for the international DBS that
isn't something we can do we could put
the owners on
the applicant to do it or to provide us
with something but that isn't something
we can do in this country or you just
yeah
sorry Council I've just Googled it and
there is something on the gov dot UK
website which says that you can get a
criminal check record check for time
spent abroad so that could possibly be a
possibility
[Music]
yeah I think going forward because as
we're talking about you know people
doing school runs I think it is very
important to safeguard
and I think that should be something
that the
person's personal cost if they want to
do the job fine but they should have to
provide us with a DPS from their own
country DBS
Council Huxley
thanks chair just could you just sort of
um do synopsis Alison of
um what are the local authorities are
doing so saying Kent sorry I haven't had
time to read it it's
you know are they doing what we're
thinking doing or are they doing
completely different things or
yeah it's on nxc if you look at some of
them I mean
you know you could say we're quite
behind in what we do you've got some of
the others who make them do an actual
taxi driving assessment course
um which you know ranges from 70 to 90
pounds that obviously puts a lot more
cost on the whole process
um there's quite a few do that as you
can see there's quite a few that they
still have their written knowledge tests
they've got all sorts of various bits
within it they all charge different fees
um
everybody does something different which
isn't ideal
it would be handy if the government says
for Department of Transport or someone
said this is the test this is what
you've got to do these are the bits
you've got to add in it but at the
moment every Council can do whatever
they want which isn't helpful
councilor Curry
thank you
yeah I do feel with the advancement with
um
cab technology sat navs the Knowledge
Test does have to be looked at I I don't
think the uh the drivers these days need
an extensive
knowledge of the local area but as you
say with the the Hackney cabs it's
different and a tourist
section of the um
[Music]
the knowledge test would be a good idea
I'd also like to hear your views on this
there's been some support for a
practical test where a driver would um
accompany and look at driving knowledge
of Highway code English and maths and
encompassing all that into one practical
test what's your views on that
um
are you do you mean an in-house
I think it would be of course yeah it
would be with a an officer who would
accompany yeah I mean if if that was the
route you want to go down it would mean
employing someone else yeah
um because
practice you know practice they they
have to they would have to go on various
courses especially with things like
safeguarding that you've got train the
trainer you've got all sorts of courses
that have to go on
um it would probably be as you can see
with some of the other authorities it
would probably be a five to six hour
course that they would obviously have to
come in and do and then at the end of it
a short exam still short test
um as for the driving side of it that's
a bit more specialist
um again you could send drivers for a
driving exam with one of the the Blue
Lamp or the green Penny there's all of
those Alternatives but of course that
that puts a lot
you know it would put a lot more on the
cost of the whole thing
um if we did do some sort of In-House
training
um again driving assessment you know I
mean like last week most weeks we're
getting on average 20 candidates because
we have to obviously space them out and
it depends on room availability
um so if you've got somebody having to
test 20 odd people on their driving
ability
it's you know it would be a full-time
job probably
yeah it can I just ask you and obviously
that you know you'd have to have
somebody who's qualified
with you know like a obviously driving
instructors are qualified yeah you know
how to use yeah the officer there have
been awful lot of training yeah yeah I
understand that and can I ask you as far
as the Knowledge Test
um I see there's there's four main areas
there's the driver policy and conditions
the local area knowledge the numeracy
assessment and then the highway code
which we you wouldn't touch because the
safety side has to be Paramount here I
just wondered what areas
um are the drivers failing in mainly on
the Knowledge Test
that sort of it's it's mainly on that
proportion but as you can see in there
we've put that the scores should be 18
18 10 and 5. we don't stick to that yeah
um
because I have looked at some of the
questions within the papers
um it was written before I took on this
role and I do feel that some of the
questions in there are quite ambiguous
even though they're multiple choice when
you actually read them some of them you
could answer two of them two of them
could be slightly correct they're a bit
you know
um
what's up oh yeah
um they're a bit they are a bit
ambiguous some of the questions so I do
think they do need looking at so when
the team have when the guys whoever's
done the knowledge test they get the
papers back they mark them if they feel
that there's some that are you know
nearly there they give me the papers and
I will go through it
um like some last week they got 16 15 10
and 5. and so we look at the questions
and think or if they've done it a couple
of times or they've done it and they've
really improved it's like oh well yeah
you know they're fine but like with the
highway code questions one of them on
there is the 20 mile an hour sign
two people last week ticked the option
that means only 20 cars can be in this
area at any one time
you know let's there's only five Highway
code questions there the good thing
there is that once they've been told the
answer to that they know it you hope so
yeah they won't get that wrong again but
we won't if they get questions wrong we
don't tell them
we don't tell them the specific
questions they've got wrong we will say
you need improving in this area you've
you need improving in your um the
safeguarding side of things or the
disability we will tell them what areas
they've failed in but we obviously don't
tell them what questions they've got
wrong
we've got three papers some obviously
each paper has different questions we
try and make sure that each paper is not
the same so that each time they come
it's a different paper but that area is
somewhat something that could be looked
at and improved for sure yeah okay thank
you very much and also with um
driving licenses for people who've
obviously come over here from the EU
they can just transfer their license to
a British license there's no test
there's no Theory there's no nothing
so that doesn't always help either with
their knowledge of the highway code and
you know everything else
so we can't have questions in the public
um you were notified for that
I just wanted to basically
um say obviously I've read through a lot
of this I've looked at um Mr Duty's
examples of like um different
um ways of testing with different
councils I've looked at our councils
I've looked at um what the council our
council is doing currently and asked the
question why isn't this standardized why
are we sitting here at all you know like
this should be standardized over the
whole country
um I was quite taken with the idea of
the assessment center though with the um
the Worcestershire Council because
obviously our priority is to make sure
that people are safe in the taxis and I
do think that if people are having a six
hour course where they're going through
all the safeguarding the slavery license
conditions vehicle conditions I added a
few things as well that you know that
they should be going through in addition
to have you all looked at this this um
yeah the Wolverhampton
Council
yeah yeah there's a lot of information I
understand that which is why my
suggestion would be for this to be
actually taken away by the licensing
team and for them to have a look at all
these different options you know and we
talk about not Reinventing the world and
if there is something you know like you
know like is is cost effective you know
even if we need to bring somebody else
on part-time because you know like
there's no there's no price on people's
safety
um so um so that they can actually
assess this you know look at which ones
are the best so that people actually
want to come to thanet to do their taxi
driving test you know no but you know so
that we can actually sort of like set an
example good example or actually try and
collaborate with maybe Wolverhampton
Council and find out how they do it and
then the application and fee wouldn't
need to be paid for until after they
completed the assessment day but during
that that six hours which maybe we could
have somebody in-house doing or we could
Outsource to maybe one of these training
providers and we would have a very good
idea whether this person these are a
proper fit people you know like to
actually work in work in um work for our
taxi companies amazing thing that you've
got funding from bwks and it's linked to
the doctors
the arrange child about 18 ewt to help
its trading okay all right so yeah okay
um thank you
um so so I mean um has anybody else you
know like um had similar thoughts about
the assessment center
um and um whether they think that that's
a good idea for us to be exploring as a
council
um so that we can ensure the safety of
our community
I agree with you chair I think it's a
good way forward it's positive
yeah I think and in-house trading course
would be really good
or someone to do it as an assessment
yeah
it was Council Portsmouth and then
councilor Curry
my only worry with that is it's going to
take longer and longer to get this all
in place and I do think we are really
lacking at the moment in this area with
taxi drivers and this area is suffering
with the with a lack of taxi drivers and
I do trust the licensing team that
they've been doing this job and know
what the legalities are to steer us
proper in that respect it's my only
thoughts
yeah no I hear what you're saying I mean
obviously this isn't going to be
something that's done overnight
um so um um so obviously you know we'd
have to look at
um an interim solution
um but I'm just talking about you know
actually looking at this you know
getting somebody on board now to start
looking at it and reassessing
um our assessment process
look away
yeah I just wanted to mention as well
for anybody who wasn't aware that
drivers could go to Wolverhampton and
take the test there which uh yeah
because
okay maybe cheaper but the fact that
they can do that is uh councilor Brooke
has a lot of response to that about them
going to Wolverhampton
are you running are you
um
if they do that it's basically called
the trend Trinity of licenses If a
driver goes and gets licensed by
Wolverhampton their vehicle has to be
and the operator has to be all three
would have to be licensed with
Wolverhampton and obviously if that
happens
we have no control over that vehicle or
that driver because any complaints that
may come in from the local area
they would have to be directed to
Wolverhampton
Council Huxley in the old days the good
old days you couldn't if you're a
private hard vehicle operator or a taxi
driver you couldn't work outside of your
local area as in thanet
so the government changed the law
um Allison
we currently have just a bit of info 391
licensed private high drivers
and we've got seven that are currently
going through their renewal process and
so far this year we've licensed nine new
ones
we obviously with the licensing officers
they do spot checks on drivers
um
so we do keep an eye on them but there
was recently last year there was an
issue between two drivers and we ended
up speaking to them both and one of the
drivers told us he was working for an
operator we contacted that operator
hadn't worked for him for months we
contacted other operators never heard of
the guy so we ended up taking his plate
and his badge off of him because he
couldn't tell us who he was working for
so why was he driving around with that
plate and that badge if he wasn't
actually working for anybody and we took
it off of him and we said once you can
say you know you're going to work for
United show whatever
um
we'll let you have it back he's never
come back to us
quite quite a few of them they do just
eat work they visual the vehicle last
week he opened the boot there's his just
eat bag in the back
so if this is a internal
um board meeting for discussion
[Music]
oh okay I thought we were supposed to it
said but notice it wasn't it wasn't
public
speaking that's not an issue
right okay knowledge
so sorry sorry okay all right
okay obviously obviously you know right
like um we are here today to discuss
um the the Knowledge Test
um and if there needs to be any changes
to that Knowledge Test Now as yeah look
as as you know I was talking about I
think we need to have a complete
reassessment of it a reassessment to see
if we need an assessment center
um in the interim though um I don't know
if um that we want to make any changes
as regards to the online component of
this whether that should be done
in-house so that we know it's actually
done by the person
um
as something that we could actually ask
to be looked at straight away
obviously we'd have to have someone
who's fully trained in the safeguarding
side of things
um there may be offices they are
officers within the authority that are
safeguarding but
um they don't work for our department so
obviously it's whether they've got the
time or whatever to be able to pass that
over or of course the other option is to
do the slightly more expensive 25 pound
course
which is done online but obviously they
have to prove who they are with their
picture and they have to sit there in
sort of a classroom more of a classroom
type of
course
rather than just answering questions or
not
slides
puzzle pot
I agree I think it should only be done
in front because you need to prove your
ability to work in this country you're
you're a driving license and everything
else that goes with becoming a taxi
driver and I think we should just all be
done in-house you could you can have as
many sittings as you've got the time to
do
so I can't see a problem and if somebody
wants to become a taxi driver I would
happily pay 25 pounds uh a course
happily
of course I'm talking about the 25 pound
one it's still done online
it's still done online it's the Blue
Lamp one that is still done online but
it is
it's like a teams meeting so the trainer
can see everybody's faces and can see
who's actually doing it which is unlike
the current online one
right yeah I'm with you now so but they
still have to come in for the rest
that's fine
thank you councilor Curry
yeah and I think in the short term um
can we look at um 3.2 make changes to
the test lower the Pass rates or end or
split the test into a longer Hackney
driver test more local knowledge and a
private hire driver test with less local
knowledge and review all the questions
I think that's what we've discussed
as well
councilor Huxley thanks chair and then
uh in the long term uh 3.3
so employing a member assault to train
all aspects of the test
have an internal review
as you were talking about
as a long term
a solution
thanks
I mean so in the short term we could
actually
um have it as a 25 pound test where it's
like verifiable and and we also just we
also talked about maybe lowering the
price of the second if they fail the
first time so um so it's what you found
the first time but maybe lower it
when they come back second timer so I'm
just talking about an interim period
while while you're assessing the whole
thing
um I don't know um because at the moment
if they fail they have to come back and
pay the 40 pound again don't they I mean
I
what do other people think about
um um if you fail the test
um the first time and when you come back
you're a reduced rate
which is a combat because they want to
really want to do this so you know to
charge them the same I think they should
be cut down definitely yeah
cancer shop yeah um when do you do the
meetings where they come in and do the
test is it daytime yeah it's fortnightly
um 10 o'clock 10 o'clock because I have
had a couple of people say to me they
haven't bothered to come back after they
didn't pass the first time because they
work all day every day would you
consider doing once every so often an
evening one
but no one's actually ever come to us
and said we can't do it during the day
so if there are people who
can't do it during the day then we could
look at maybe once a month doing an
evening course doing an evening
knowledge yeah no problem okay I'll let
them know because uh
that would probably help get a few more
in
do we have a um do we have an idea of
what we would reduce the um the price to
on the second time round
half price
so we're saying 40 pound the first time
and then 20 41 currently 41 pounds yes
we kept it we didn't up it with
everything else okay and then up 20
pounds a second time
what and then half again the third time
they said so 20 pound for repeat tests
then and then and add an evening Course
once a month
okay
and there's something that you said
councilor pots wasn't there something
else
about possibly having another tier for
school
and drivers only
and also an international DBS
obviously at the driver's expense
it's National criminal check yeah
so things that we can do immediately are
the the 25 pound online test where they
have to produce their proper ID
um and is to have the evening course as
well
um and reduce the second one to 20
pounds
um resets to 20 pounds
and then things like what you said um
Council reports they'll have to go in
the overall
review
um councilor Curry can the officers look
at 3.2 as we've discussed
are you talking about low in the past
rate
so can you
uh yeah this would be yeah 3.2 a longer
Hackney driver test with more local and
touristy knowledge and private hire
driver tests with less local knowledge
and to review all the questions
um yes so to put that in as part of the
whole review the whole review when
they're looking at um changing over to
maybe more of an assessment sent
assessment day format
yeah so that so that they would be
different the questions would be
different
um
it's about finding the best way the best
structure and Best Way Forward
um looking at all the other the other
the other models or actually approaching
external training providers
just to say really
obviously there's a few things that are
different I mean obviously with
safeguarding disability and everything
that's all the same
you've got obviously a taxi private give
me words like a taxi a Hackney Carriage
comply For Hire whereas a private high
vehicle can't but some of the drivers
don't know the difference still you know
we've we've asked a private higher
driver about that and he's like what's
applying for hire so they should still
really know each other's
what what each other can and can't do
um but I think the Hackney should have
more of local knowledge or groups A to B
you know how do you get from A to B
what's the shortest route from there so
but I do think they they need to they do
need to know each other what each other
can and can't do because they do get
that confused still sometimes
well I just want to add to that that
obviously Hackney carriages can work
private higher
so they can work for a for an operator
so if you're just asking them to just do
the Hackney Carriage Knowledge Test
there could be a falling in there
because they can work private higher
[Music]
so I just want to recap to where we're
up to then
um 40 down to 20 second pass evening
course online 25 pound with ID and
that's for now and the licensing
department will conduct a full analysis
of um that their current testing
structure and and look at different
assessment centers Etc and then bring
that back to us bring that back to the
committee yeah okay and we need to time
frame on that I guess
what do you think of reasonable time
frame would be Alison
yeah when have you got you won't have
anything booked in yet will you Stephen
for July June July no not yet no
but what what honestly I mean there is a
lot of information to look at I mean
what reasonably do you think I mean is
is June reasonable or
um I mean always or would you need to
know Mark
Duke yeah June or July I mean obviously
we're also looking at I know you guys
probably saw it before the actual policy
the private hiring Hackney policy it was
originally went out pre-covered
um so that's all being looked at again
because there's been quite a lot of
other changes within government again
with legislation of what we can and
can't do and everything so that's that's
being revised at the moment and we're
hoping to bring that to board in June so
that'll be quite a major thing for
whoever's on board at that time to to
look at
um but obviously Within part of that is
will be
what the knowledge test consist of so we
can try and look at the two going along
together
so hope
fully budget yeah yeah
does anybody have any more um questions
for Alison
that's Curry yeah just one more because
I've mentioned in three points so it's
just not to conflute the the situation
looking at 3.4 change the test to
include a driver assessment course
would it be possible to incorporate
parts of the 3.2 option into 3.4 so I
noticed that the 3.4 option would be um
uh online classroom calls for
safeguarding
um both PayPal and a shortened in-house
knowledge tests would you be able to
marry the toe yeah
oh you're that 3.4
um is talking about a different type of
assessment test to what you've been
talking about 3.4 is talking about
there's
um a driver assessment course that Blue
Lamp and Penny do which are between 70
and 80 pounds so that's a totally
different driver of course
um that's assessing their driving so you
could have that and then you could have
the Online safety guard safeguarding
course that you're talking about the 25
pound one and then we could still do a
shortened Knowledge Test in-house just
as we do now or if you want to go down
the full in-house training route
obviously the driver assessment course
wouldn't necessarily be part of it
because that means someone having to go
with the driver to assess their driving
so it's like I say it is a total
Minefield every Council does something
different and it would be so good if it
was the government just said this is
what they've got to do that's the end of
it
but
you know they don't
and we agreed on what we're doing
yeah so so
um we're gonna have a full licensing
um team are going to do a full
reassessment of um their testing
um procedure and look at um these
um
in-house assessments so that we can get
a clear idea of these people that are
going through our system and that are
going to be um trained to become or or
become our taxi drivers basically pass
in these tests so um
that's why I was asking if you'd all
looked at you know things like the
Worcestershire you know the
Wolverhampton model
and then um then they would apply for
the application reform after that once
they've passed I mean this is a 75
percent
pass and 75 they need to achieve in the
exam at the end of the day but I mean
you look at you'd look at that but in
the interim we can make those other
changes that we talked about that can be
done immediately
yes so um
those changes being the 40 pound and the
first time around 20 pounds Second Time
Around evening Course once a month and
I'd immediately
um putting that um online
um 25 pound course
as part of the um the test procedure at
the moment
yeah
is that okay is that okay with everybody
and then and then you're going to bring
it back in at the end of June aren't you
yeah yeah
proposal counselor Schwab
secondary councilor at cylinders
okay
does everyone agree
yeah it wants a Grace that's great
thank you and then
I think that concludes the meeting okay
thank you very much everybody